어 미국 대선에서 트럼프가 압도적으로
승리를 했습니다 어 우선 압도적으로
승리한 이유 중에 하나가 저는 가장
큰게 물가 거 같아요 워낙 지금
미국이 물가가 높기 때문에 시민들의
이게 직접적인 좀 영향이 되잖아요 어
제가 최근에도 미국 출장 갔을 때
물가가 진짜 너무 비쌌어요 비용이
많이 나왔거든요 물가가 지금 워낙
높기 때문에 지금 바이든 정부에 대한
불만이 되게 많거든요 그리고 또 한
가지는 바이든 정부 때는 이민자들이
굉장히 좀 많이 들어왔어요 아무래도
거기에 이제 뭐 불법 이민자들이 많이
와서 뭐 이런 사건 사고를 좀 많이
일으키고 문제가 됐던 경우가 되게
많았거든요 트럼프는 이런 불법
이민자를 막겠다 어 무조건 못
들어오게 다
추방시키고 시민들한테 좀 이제 열렬한
지지를 좀 받은 거 같습니다네 그래서
그런 점 때문에 트럼프가 좀
압도적으로 당선이 되지 않았나 어
이렇게 생각을 합니다 어 우리나라를
비교를 해야 되는데 우리나라 경제
성장률은 그렇게 높지 않을 거 같아요
어찌됐든 환율도 되게 높은 상태고
트럼프 자체 가 자국 우선주의를 더
추구할 거기 때문에 수출로 먹고 사는
우리나라 같은 경우에는 좀 타격이
있지 않나 뭐 이렇게 예상을 합니다
그리고 트럼프가 중국 관세를 뭐
60% 이상 부과하겠다 뭐 이런
발언도 했는데 사실 60% 이상 부각
기기는 쉽지 않을 것 같아요 제
생각엔 워낙이 트럼프가 딜을 하는
사람이어서 일단은 높게 부른 다음에
아마 협상을 하지 않을까 근데
아무래도 지금
우리나라 같은 경우에도 그런 관세
아든 이런 규제들이 좀 많이 생겨나지
않을까 생각을 합니다 저희가 뭐
반도체라는 뭐 자동차 산업 이런
사업들이 주력 사업이 아아 우리나라에
근데 그런 사업들이 좀 영향을 많이
받을지 않을까네 이렇게 예상을 합니다
뭐 IMF to 그렇고 여러 리서치
발표하는 데서 우리나라 경제 성장률을
계속 좀 낮추고 있거든요 내년이나
아니면 대통령 그 4년 기간 동안은
좀 경제 성장률이 좀 이렇게 주춤하지
않을까네 이렇게 예상을 조심이
해봅니다 트럼 프가 뭐 방위비를 엄청
부각했다 그 얘기 많이 했잖아요 뭐
한국 돈 많이 버는데 왜 방위비를
많이 부담 안 하냐 이런 발언들을
많이 했는데 연장 계약을 최근에 하긴
했어요 뭐 다시 이렇게 돌리기가 쉽진
않긴 하지만 제 예상컨대 뭐 트럼프가
워낙 이제 말을 많이 바꿔서 그것도
좀 뭐 바뀔 가능성도 뭐 있다라고
저는 생각을 합니다 개인적으로
트럼프가 이제 대통령이 된다라고
하면은 우리나라에는 그런 환율이
어쨌든 수출 부분에 대한 문제
방위비뿐만 아니라 여러 분야에 대해서
좀 직접적으로 어 영향을 좀 끼치지
않을까 이렇게 좀 예상을 하고
있습니다 트럼프 대통령 뭐 첫 번째도
어 경험을 해 봤지만 바이든 때도
사실 뭐 그렇게 나아진 건 없었던 거
같아요 언론 플레이를 잘하는 트럼프다
보니까 막 되게 세게 얘기한 거
같은데 근데 또 생각보다 이렇게 안
될 수도 있어요 관세도 생각보다 안
올릴 수도 있고 그냥 방위비 그냥
그대로 갈 수도 있고 어찌됐든 미국이
또 수출도 해야 되거든요네 수출도
적극적으로 하려면 환율을 그렇게
높게는 계속 못할 겁니다 환율을 좀
낮춰야지 수익성이 좋기 때문에
언론에서 얘기했던 거보다는 다른
방향으로 갈 여지도 충분히 있다라고
생각합니다 양극화가 더 심해질 거
같아요 오르는 데는 계속 오르고
떨어지는 데는 계속 떨어지고 저는
부동산 투자할 때 항상 말씀드리는게
환금성이 생각하거든요 그래서 언제든지
시장에 내놨을 때 팔릴 만한 어
부동산을 사야 되는데 아마 그게 되게
심해질 겁니다 그리고 여러분들이 또
같이 보셔야 되는 것 중에 하나가
우리나라 주식은 안 좋잖아요 지금
최근에도 막 삼성전자 뭐 4만 전
해가지고 내려가는데 저는 이제 처음
봤어요 4만 원대 된게 진짜 뭐 얼마
전만 해도 뭐 7만 전자 8만 전자
뭐 10만 전자 간자 막 그랬는데
지금 한국 주식도 매우 안 좋습니다
그래서이 사람들이 다 지금 어디
갔냐면 미국 주식으로 많이 갔잖아요
그래서 지금 미국 주식은 워낙
좋습니다 맨날 이제 최고가를 경신할
정도로 미국 주식으로 돈 버는
사람들이 되게 많아졌어요 트럼프가
암호 화폐 친화적인 대통령이라고
하잖아요 코인 가격이 굉장히 많이
올랐는데 어 만약에 이제 집권하게
된다면이 코인 가격은 뭐 계속 오를
거 같습니다 근데 이거 를 제가 왜
말씀드리면 이게 다 연결돼 있어요
그래서 저희가 만약에 입장을 바꿔서
보면은 제가 만약에 코인을 50억을
벌었다고 하면 일단 집을 사고
싶잖아요 좀 이렇게 상징적인 집을
많이 사려고 할 것 같아요 뭐 예를
들어서 트로피 성격의 부동산들은 계속
최고가를 경신할 거 같아요 뭐 원밸리
아니면 뭐 아서포든지 이런 뭔가
상징적인 부동산들은 계속 좀 최고가를
경신할 거 같고 거기 펜트하우스도
아마 말도 안 되는 가격이 계속 다
팔릴 겁니다 최고가를 경신하는 주거
시설들 보면은 코인부자 분들이 되게
많거든요 뭐 80년대 90년대 생들이
되게 많은데 그래서 앞으로 더 많이
생겨날 겁니다 그리고 빌딩도 진짜
최고가를 다 경신할 거예요 아 뭔가
부동산 사고 싶다 빌딩 사고 싶다라고
해서 그냥 위치 좋은 걸 최고가로
계속 살 겁니다 그래서 좀 정리를 해
보자면 오르는 데는 계속 오를거다
어찌됐든 인구가 계속 좀 줄어들고
있고 초고령화 사회로 좀 접어들었어요
많은 분들이 이제 초고령화 사회
되면은 뭐 부동산 다 폭망할거다 망할
거다라고 하는데 저는 오르는 데는
계속 오를 겁니다 지금 일본을
보더라도 도쿄에 인 지역은 가격이
계속 올라요 뭐 최근 같은 경우에는
제가 아자부다이 힐즈 갔었는데 거기
최고가에 팔린게 하나로과의 거의 한
1700억 정도 됩니다 그 정도로
매각된 사례가 있을 정도로 트로피
성격의 부동산들은 가격이 계속
올랐어요 그러니까 돈 있어도 살 수가
없는 부동산입니다 일본이 뭐 우리나라
10년 뒤 20년뒤 모습이라고
하잖아요 어찌됐든 지금 초고령화
사회로 접어들었고 나중에 10년 뒤
20년 뒤 그 이상을 봤을 때도 주요
지역에 있는 부동산들은 계속 올라갈
거라고 저는 생각합니다 매번
말씀드리지만 일단은 잘 팔리는 동네의
부동산을 사야 됩니다 트로피 성격의
부동산 해외 주식이나 부동산 아 뭐
코인 투자하시는 분들이 좋아할 만한
뭔가 그런 부동산을 사야지 그분들이
계속 최고가를 찍어 줄 거고 계속 사
줄 거고 그럼 이제 가격이 덩달아서
오르거든요 어찌됐든 환율이 되게
높잖아요 그래서 지금 10000원이
넘었는데 1400원을 넘는게
우리나라에 몇 번 안 됩니다 IMF
때 한 번 2008년도 금융위기 때
한 번 그다음에 코로나 이후에 어 곡
완전 금리 많이 올릴 때 한 번
그리고 2번 에거 우리나라 역사상
그렇게 많지 않아요 원화가치가 계속
좀 떨어지고 있는 상황입니다
극단적으로 설명드리자면 지금 원화를
다 진짜 달러로 바꿔야 됩니다 어떻게
봐 달러 표시 자산을 투자하거나
누구나 다 알 만한 그런 아파트라는
부동산이라는 이런 거를 투자해야이
원화가 떨어지는 거를 방어하지 않을까
어 이렇게 예상을 합니다 정리를 해
보자면 이번에 이제 트럼프가 당선이
되면서 경제가 좀 많이 달라질 수도
있을 것 같아요 좀 수출도 어려 지고
환율도 계속 좀 높은 상태로 유지가
되고 그래서 되게 어려운 상황이 될
수 있겠지만 좀 일단은 만약에 이제
지금 같은 시기에 투자를 한다라고
하면은 무조건 위치 좋은데 어
부동산을 투자하는게 정답입니다
장기적으로 봤을 때 지금 사실 흔히
얘기하는 그런 단타가 아니잖아요 막
갑자기 샀다가 1년 뒤에 팔고 막
그런게 아니잖아요 기본 사면은 5년
뭐 10년 그 이상을 보유하는데
나중에 5년뒤 10년뒤를 봤을 때 그
주요 지역에 있는 괜찮은 부동산들이
아마 가격이 더 많이 올 좋 것
같습니다 격차가 더 심해질 거고
양극화가 더 심해질 겁니다이 부분을
기억하셔도 좀 2025년 부동산 투자
계획을 좀 세우셨으면
[음악]
좋겠습니다 I